hey guys how's it going said Allah ask
you guys on snapchat or some ask IJ
questions I'm not really sure how the
better answer these from snapchat but
let's let's uh let's see we can do our
first question comes from Alec who's
asking me how you feel about that ariana
grande and the whole donut incident
first of all okay this is this is what I
think about the donut incident I think
did she lick the donuts or something I'm
not sure if they were more upset about
licking of the donuts or the fact that
she said she hates America her apology I
kind of understand where she's coming
from
not actually meaning she hates America I
don't know I don't know I'm not really
sure what I'm saying I take me to the
donut shop I keep going cuz I don't
really know how I feel I don't really
know the whole story so I can't really
comment on how I feel about the story I
don't really know the whole story if you
guys want with let me know the whole
story leave it in the comments below
either way don't look somebody else
doughnuts or move on what's the weirdest
name that you've ever gotten from
Starbucks I usually get Justin weirdest
one though was when they called me
Jenna's friend my sister Jenna got her
coffee in the here hood online Jenna's
friend clearly could sever forever
friend will you come to Toronto for your
book tour I would love to I've only been
to Canada once and I was in Niagara
Falls no I lied I was in a hole in
Montreal yes I would love to go back to
Canada Lyndon Thornton once this chanel
if I will ever get a boyfriend again
uh-huh yes Lyndon I'm sure I will
at some point that will happen uh I'm in
no hurry thank you very much have I
dropped my iphone six-plus yet
yes actually I have I have dropped it on
my face who would have been coming back
to Indy because I might need an IJ Indy
fast huh huh Arnel you just said that I
had such a great time at the Indy 500
and I'm a huge IndyCar racing fan I've
actually been following you have the in
the app on my phone so anytime there's
races I get all of them notifications
ported Pumped Apple didn't exist what
phone would I have a great question I'm
sure there would be some sort of crazy
amazing technology that I would be
holding in my hand right now currently
I'm holding the iPhone and I'm actually
not wearing my Apple watch I haven't had
it on all day when will you be doing the
cooking video I've got a couple cooking
videos lined up for you guys I'm kind of
excited about it one is something that I
may
and I actually didn't mess it up I can't
believe it
James Winson oh my most awkward moment
is my life is sometimes awkward I feel
like a lot of social situations are a
little awkward sometimes we're doing
meetups the really awkward because I
don't know what to say to you guys and
you guys were to say to me so I just
like give you a big hug and say I love
you you don't get a lot of time with
people when you meet them at Meetup
so you try to make every second count
and you don't want to disappoint
somebody and I just I just want to make
sure that you guys are happy and excited
is do you have people pushing you
through would like no what I want to
talk to them longer please level gothic
won't snow gonna be getting the new
Animal Crossing and yes I will
definitely be getting it I have so much
fun playing Animal Crossing like I
played the crap out of that I played it
so much that I think my real life
started to suffer
Elton Munson it my favorite subject was
in school I think my favorite subject
probably was your book class I
absolutely loved it because I got to go
run and took photos I got to lay out the
yearbook I also really loved computer
math class so in computer math we did
programming and in our free time we
played when we played quake 3 so there
really sometimes both in a lot of work
going on John wants to know how large my
Lego collection is I've actually been
reorganizing my Legos sets and
everything so I had them all and I moved
them and I put them into a box and now a
lot of them fell apart it's kind of
devastating so I don't want to show you
right now but it seems like if I'm all
set back up I'll give you a little
minifigure tour it's so sad
there's like there's a box of bodies
what bodies in that school Pine Hills
are flat flat I hate wearing high heels
I like how I feel and how I look in them
how I actually feel no I feel awful I'm
uncomfortable
not fun so I favorite drink at Starbucks
I've actually been really enjoying the
Oprah cinnamon chai tea latte cake
recently sometimes dairy upsets my
stomach a little bit so I can't get them
every day if I'm not drinking that I
just do like a black coffee a new cold
brew coffee it's pretty good
my last question I am big mike is asking
if I have any regrets it's funny because
when bad things happen a lot of times I
will
gret my decision or I'll regret decision
of someone else but in the grand scheme
of things
anytime something bad happens or even
something good or sometimes something
that you might regret doing you learn
from that situation and what I love is
later being able to reflect upon said
terrible situation or awful thing that
happened or even a situation that might
not have ended terribly would you
potentially might have regretted it you
learn from it and sometimes if you're
smart you won't make that same mistake
more than once
or more than twice or three times you
can make it more than once it depends on
what it is I don't really have any
regrets actually the limit that I think
I would regret is making so many
multiple YouTube channels but I quickly
figured out that it's really unnecessary
and now I just have like my three I've
got my main channel my other I just
Union and my gaming channel I don't need
anymore
before you didn't have playlists on
YouTube so I needed a way to sort of
separate the content but yeah that's
really that's really it so I will leave
you guys with a hello and a goodbye make
sure you guys leave me some questions
below in the comments and I will use
some of those for the next episode of
ask IJ alright we'll see you guys soon
you call me baby I know I'm not the only
one